wow that is a lot of stuff to talk about
including but not limited to star wars
the star wars alone
is mind-blowingly immense in terms of
the
things i could talk about of which i'm
probably not going to hit
98 of it so i i gotta pick i'm gonna
pick and choose a couple things i want
to talk about and make a video about
that
i'm just one guy before we get into it
initially i already had my thoughts
about
alfred molina's doc ock coming into the
new spider-man movie
and i was like let me wait until today
because there's gonna be a lot of
announcements and
generally i didn't hear anything new on
that subject other than it ties into
multiverse of madness which
i think we figured so if you still want
to hear my thoughts on the doc ock thing
i have them just let me know but for now
i'm going to pick
a couple of star wars things i want to
talk about
and that would be hayden christensen
coming back and an ahsoka tano spin-off
show and yeah hayden christensen is
coming back
as darth vader not anakin skywalker but
darth vader he's coming back in the
obi-wan kenobi series
that takes place 10 years after revenge
of the set but i find it interesting in
terms of the timeline and the fact that
hayden's coming back as darth vader it
sounds like
he's gonna be in the suit which i guess
is kind of cool it's not like we're
gonna get the anakin skywalker good
anakin force ghost
after he's been darth vader because i
feel like that's what some people want
to say like i'd like to see that i would
like to see
anakin skywalker's force ghost after
he's been darth vader
give his thoughts just you know on the
horrid things he's done of the past
and timing being everything that would
have been a good time for it
so it's not gonna be that i don't know
if it's gonna be a flashback but
i think generally if he's darth vader in
this series he's gonna be in the zoo and
maybe we'll see him without the helmet
in which case it'll be hayden
christensen's face but i don't know if
that'll add to
more continuity or the feeling of less
continuity because on one hand it's like
oh hey darth vader looks like hayden
christensen on the other hand darth
vader doesn't look like sebastian shaw
who played anakin skywalker
at the end of return of the jedi so i
guess it's give and take and i think
that's where animation has the leg
up on live action in a scenario like
this because when darth vader gets his
mask
slashed and rebels and he looks over
you're like that does look and feel like
clone wars era anakin he's just evil now
that's cool it's awesome it's the
advantage of not having to rely on
actors looking identical to maintain
that feeling of continuity but that said
kathleen kennedy said yes it'll be the
what did you say the rematch of the
century which implies that they fight i
won't lie i do like the concept that
obi-wan
invader their first conflict after
revenge of the sith wasn't a new hope
but it's doing that star wars
series thing which is what star wars
series do which is to patch up the
continuity holes that exist in the
movies because when luke tells vader in
return of the jedi come with me turn
good
vader says obi-wan once thought as you
did but in revenge of the sith lb1 was
like i will do what i must which is kill
you so this could be that moment where
obi-wan was like all right
trying to kill him didn't help that
15-minute fight didn't help things maybe
i can try to get him to turn good and
when he tries to do that maybe
he senses like vader's too far gone for
me so although a conflict between
obi-wan and darth vader
in between revenge of the sith and a new
hope wasn't strictly speaking planned in
terms of canon
it doesn't not make sense so you can do
it i just i would like to see a more
emotional story with obi-wan kenobi you
know i don't need
the exciting space fights and the sci-fi
adventure
i would like to see an old man
who lost his entire religion all of his
friends were killed
by his best friend there was this
the stigma for a while where it was like
people who did the prequels were like oh
the prickles i don't wanna nope i'm done
with the brick walls but ewan mcgregor
and hayden christensen both coming back
it kind of shows how
those movies and the characters are ah
they're good with the fans
fans love them and it feels like star
wars love if he's mostly in the suit
i feel like he could have gotten most
anybody in the suit granted
in rogue one a star wars story vader's
shoulders are a bit more
hunched down and hunched over than david
prouses were so
you know that darth vader physical
stature
matters and hayden christensen was in
the suit in revenge of the sith so he
does work for it so that's cool also an
ahsoka series spin-off which really
shows what the mandalorian is like the
mandalorian is this weird little hub
of now known previously unknown property
of the mandalorian i mean people know
who mandalorians are but
this character the star of the
mandalorian mando himself
he's new so it's about this season with
spoilers for this season by the way with
bo katan
ahsoka tano it's like the mandalorians
this little hub to possibly spin off
other
star wars tv shows from it from
previously existing characters that show
up in it and thus they are doing that
with ahsoka which rosario dawson
as ahsoka i thought she was good i know
there are some people who are like the
voice
doesn't it's not the voice they're used
to which i totally get but for live
action ahsoka tano i thought rosario
dawson was i thought she was great but
again this is fascinating because
there are possibilities here i see
possibility most of which
i find intriguing this is where you
start seeing these threads
linked together that all tie back to
mandalorian because ahsoka is looking
for grand admiral thrawn
i don't know if she's looking for thrawn
and ezra if she believes
thrawn will bring her to ezra or she
just wants to find thrawn point is
i'm interested in that premise i'm
interested in the premise here it is on
paper
anakin skywalker's former apprentice is
looking for grand admiral thrawn
yeah i mean i'm there for it regardless
this is that moment
where you could have that conversation
between luke and ahsoka
or that post return of the jedi good
force ghost anakin
skywalker conversation about the sins of
his past maybe he's just catching up
with his former apprentice
point is um you could have forced ghost
hayden christensen anakin skywalker
come in and also have a conversation
there are all these possibilities that
could happen just
for the life of me when i reflect on the
sequel trilogy
i have no idea why anakin skywalker's
force ghost didn't intervene
anywhere point is i'm interested that
hayden christensen's coming back as
darth vader and the ahsoka series has a
lot of potential that you could do
with her and her connection with anakin
with the force those are my thoughts on
you know the couple things the things
where i was like all right gonna pick
that to talk about that to talk about
the rest slip through that enormous
crack that
all those things could possibly slip
through because it's a lot there's a lot
of star wars news
that i'm not covering i just i was like
okay what's the talk about oh my god
that's just kind of how it goes time was
people were like hey disney maybe you
should space out the star wars movies
because
you know that weight in between is kind
of what makes it special
let's come to our attention here at
disney that people would like us to
scale back the release of star wars
movies and space it out because they
like them feeling special and we get
that we hear you
and that's why we have a star wars movie
to announce
rogue squadron the n64 game the end
specifically what now
doesn't so that would be your star wars
movie you're getting
because we're ramping up a metric [ __ ]
ton of star wars series coming
exclusively to disney plus
but the most important thing to us and
this is the most important thing is to
protect these characters have them live
on in the way george created them
wouldn't you agree what's so funny well
that shirt doesn't go with that suit
well your voice doesn't go with your
beard
i see you've copied my beard you owe me
a buck 75 or even saying that in a
youtube video disney me is a
dick but i'm interested in the ahsoka
show because i figured that was going to
happen patty jenkins directing a star
wars movie i know he didn't really touch
on it too much but
that right there that that lines up to
be something that could be really good
but hayden christensen coming
back as darth vader that right there
shows where star wars is and the love of
the prequels and how they've been
validated in the eyes of the fans i
suppose it's that
trick of knowing you know when you know
is hayden christensen in that suit
face to face with obi-wan kenobi it's
just the
knowledge that'll make it feel you'll
feel that connection
you'll feel that revenge of the sith
connection i like that all right so
hayden christensen coming back is darth
vader in the obi-wan kenobi series
and ahsoka tano getting her own spin-off
series and
everything else they talked about
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you